[Music]
foreign
cliff weitzman how are you
i'm very very well i'm excited to be
here with you how are you my man thank
you for joining me in these crazy crazy
times are you safe and healthy i am self
safe and healthy up in uh northern
california wonderful
um yeah riding out the self isolation
with my family so
finding the silver lining finding the
silver let's talk in a few months and
see the silver line
all right so we met on and off over the
years
i've been um i've been a fan for many
and i just want to go back to your
childhood
because i just love it's one of the
stories that i love most uh
way before brown way before speechify
you have dyslexia
you're very open about it you wrote a
lot about it
tell me what is it like growing up with
dyslexia and the challenges it brings
sure so um so i grew up in israel
and i moved to the us when i was 13.
yeah
um and when i was in preschool i was
like the most precocious kid
that they could be i was in all the
school plays
i was like dancing i was writing songs
um and
then in first grade i couldn't figure
out how to read
in second grade i couldn't figure it out
either and in third grade i couldn't
figure it out either
and um i really wanted my parents to be
proud of me
and especially my dad and they really
valued education
and so i did too but no matter how hard
i tried i couldn't get this whole
reading thing to work
and my teachers started to think that i
was slow or or lazy
and i didn't think i was either one of
those things i thought i was awesome
i just needed to figure out how to make
the outside world realize this about me
and i um
just started practicing really hard to
try and figure out how to read
and i guess to the point where i could
read well enough but not
um you know the average reading speed in
the united states is 200 words per
minute so i got to roughly that speed
and though that speed is average it is
not adequate
if you reach a that average reading
speed you're not going to be an avid
reader and you're not going to like love
books and while reading
but eventually i found audiobooks and
initially what happened
is i really wanted to read this one book
um harry potter
and no matter how hard i tried i
couldn't figure it out so my dad
actually took pity on me and he sat with
me in my bed
and he read this book to me and i loved
it so much that he started
recording himself in a cassette tape and
he would walk
and i would walk around the house later
listening to the harry potter in hebrew
and right before we moved to the u.s we
found an audiobook with harry potter in
english and so my dad got that from me
and i started listening to that
audiobook
but i did not speak english at the time
but i knew the story really well
and i listened to harry potter and the
social stone 22 times in a row in
english and that's how i learned english
and so when i first moved to the states
i had a british accent aloha more was my
first vocabulary word
sadly i lost the accent um but
from that experience i fell in love with
audiobooks so i listen to two audiobooks
a week
every week and i've gone for about 15
years
um so more than 100 books a year and
when i started college i realized that
most
textbooks didn't have an audiobook right
most wikipedia
pages didn't have an don't audiobook
audio books yeah my emails essays i
wrote
the majority of things that we read
don't have audiobooks
and so i started using text to speech
and
yeah that changed my life too because i
was
a and there was no good text-to-speech
software at the time
and so i cobbled something together that
worked much better than the existing um
things i remember that robotic
text-to-speech that
windows has right where it's like the
robot you insert a sentence and it reads
it out in a very monotone way
i think the office made a joke with it
yeah yeah exactly he's like i i'll
compute dirt i can talk to you
and the big problem is you can't easily
enter text into that like if you have a
physical handout right you can't speech
on that yeah you can't change the speed
you can't play and pause
yeah um and so i built this software for
my computer it let me highlight the
text click the keyboard shortcut and it
would start to read it to me i built an
iphone app let me scan physical
textbooks and physical handouts
and it would read that too and then i
built a news integration into this
feature file that would actually scrape
the internet
and i could just open the app and it
will read anything i want um and
did it using deep learning um to create
really high quality voices really high
quality optical character recognition
at ocr um really high quality nlp
and it was amazing it didn't matter that
i was dyslexic from that point on
and so i actually went on to i founded
the renewable energy engineering major
at brown
and i built about 36 products when i was
in undergrad uh
because i didn't need to spend my time
doing homework um i would
long board to breakfast while listening
to my book eat breakfast for listings
for my book
um like work out show up in class and i
already knew everything because i
listened to the reading while most of
the people
um and with that spare time i just
started companies so
so cliff let's go back because you know
people are saying some people are visual
learners some are listeners
some are are you know you have to you
have to do something
active so are you do you have a gift of
being able to learn
uh through listening very very well and
is this
or or do you believe that just it's a
capacity that everybody has because you
know for me it's still
a little difficult focusing while an
audiobook is running
i find myself drifting off and all of a
sudden i'm 20 minutes in and i have no
idea where i left off
so if you look at it right we've been
listening
for 150 000 years we've been reading for
only about four thousand
and evolution doesn't move that quickly
when you start elementary school
no one expects you to read fast and no
one expects you to have high reading
comprehension in fact we expect it to
take a decade because before you become
a good reader
and listening is the same way just
slightly less extreme
so when you first listen to an audiobook
you're still not good at listening you
have to practice
and so what we find for people who use
speechify is they improve over time when
i started listening to those harry
potter audiobooks in
english i didn't even speak the language
so i wasn't listening at the 1x speed
i was listening at 50 xp and then 0.75 x
speed yeah the first couple of times
and then when i speed and then it was
natural for me to go to 1.25
and so i know many people who had the
same experience
for when they started it starts at 1.75
and then 1x and then 1.25 and 1.5 and 2x
and here's what will always happen
it takes about 10 audiobooks but on the
11th audiobook
you'll get to the point where you have
now learned this mechanism
and so retention goes up ability to
listen faster goes up
ability to multitask and do other things
while your listening goes up
and comprehension goes up and so for
most people
if you start your first audiobook you
can't expect yourself to be able to
drive and listen yeah or listening to xp
and listen
it's something that you have to practice
now like most things in life there's
predisposition
so i'm predisposed to not being very
good at doing uh the visual comp
um what is called decoding of words yeah
um therefore i compensate by being good
at listening
um and so there is a segment of the
population that is naturally better at
listening and a segment of the
population that is naturally better
your senses are heightened in one
direction to compensate for another
makes
perfect i have many friends who are
exceptional
as visual learning my friend max can sit
in one sitting finish an entire book in
two hours
but max consumes ninety percent of his
information the audiobooks
because he also practices listening
because we were really good friends
and he got into this and so he listens
to nearly as many audiobooks as i do per
year
um and it's just the case that because
when you listen
you have two hours of passive time every
single day when you're on the toilet
you're brushing your teeth you're
cleaning your room you're eating dinner
you're driving to work and in that time
you can listen
yeah but you have to make dedicated time
in order to read
and that's really hard um and so it is
important to be able to do
both um and so that's my experience so
for anyone who says oh i'm not an
auditory learner well first of all
that's fine but you have to listen to
books or read books at least consume
books in any way you want
right but for me after my parents the
number one thing that's most impacted in
my life
is books and i attribute so much of who
i am and what i've been able to
accomplish at my age
to that so that's fine if you're not an
author learner
fine but you need to be reading at least
like five books a month
if you're not reading five books a month
then you can't knock it you need to go
practice
listening as well totally okay so you're
so you started a company called
speechify
talk to me about the talk to me about
the growth where is it at now
and what what some of your responses
because at the end of the day if you go
on your website
and the first thing you do is you hear
your voice reading a book
right which is i think genius and
and one of the amazing things that you
can actually use this app
to not only read audio books but you can
read anything that your heart desires
from emails texts
to articles to physical handouts that he
just scanned
and he showed me how in two seconds you
can scan 10 pages
and have it read to you even in cliff's
voice and
so so talk to me a little bit about what
you've seen and what what what have you
learned
about this this consumer behavior
around listening yeah so right when i
was in college i built like 36 different
things
in a bunch of different categories yeah
skateboard breaks biotech supplements
payments companies websites apps etc
and when i was about to graduate i did
this experiment with myself and i was
like if it's a billionaire right now
what would i want to work on yeah and
the conclusion was i want to solve this
lesson
and so i took this product pretty
seriously and we could talk later about
how it came to be and how it got product
market fit
um but essentially it does exactly what
you describe
you can scan anything you can upload
material um you can change the speed it
has an automatic speed ramping algorithm
that improves your speed over time
and so speaking right now yeah so by the
way what speed do you listen to now how
many words per minute
when i when i listen if i'm doing it on
my computer i listen at
750 to 800 words per minute so the
average
reading space is 800 words a minute 800
right where the average reading is 200
words a minute it's 200. so i listen
four times faster than most people read
um but that's what i'm reading on my
computer
and if let's say you send me an email
i'm following with my eyes as i'm
listening with my ears
and that's reading in order to respond
it's not reading for pleasure or
for uh long term so it's dedicated
concentrated reading
dedicated concentrated reading and i'm
getting the email from you it is in
context
and then i immediately responded if i'm
walking around and i'm driving i listen
at like 550.
um and so that's the equivalent if you
listen to like podcast
at like 1.256 that's like listening to a
podcast or an audiobook at 3x speed
that's what my like
pleasure listening is um and and the
specified will coach you to do this so
what we find is usually
people when they start speechify they'll
listen to 230 words per minute
and a month in they'll be at 300. and
two months in they'll be at like 350.
really that it's that fast yeah
it is like a logarithmic logarithmic uh
it's awesome um and
here's a couple of things that were not
obvious to us uh that we learned over
time number one
you can practice listening and as you
practice listening your speed improves
yeah number two the reasons why people
were not using texas teeth before is
number
one the voices were so mechanical that
it turned people off
and so what we did is we focused on a
group of people that did not
care about the quality of the voices
people with dyslexia
apd low vision concussions the people
like me
reading is a hair on fire problem and so
if you can solve it in any way possible
they'll put up with anything and so we
just build by far
the best solution for like speech that
exists in the world um and that's why we
just had
tremendous amounts of adoption so people
listen to billions billions of words on
speechify every month
um and we get like 20 messages a week
but people will tell me hey i down i saw
your app i downloaded it i started
crying yeah
i see that yeah you have these reviews
on the app store it's crazy
um i don't know i don't know many app
reviews that
that have the sentence i started crying
when i discovered this
yeah um and
it's interesting too because um yeah no
it for for us it's like
it's the coolest thing in the world and
so we ended up building a very strong
team around us so now
we're 30 engineers and we're actually a
distributed team we're all around the
world
um and so we worked really uh we weren't
very affected by the situation we have
right now and i can go later about uh
about how hiring works this future but
now it's feature files we actually
recently started to do news within the
app
and so within uh two weeks of doing news
we're now
uh ranked the number four app in the
magazine
uh newspapers category of the app store
oh my god
and number four number four yeah we're
above the wall street journal and above
uh washington post okay yeah
wow insane wait cliff you know i
have to do i have to take a a diversion
here because you're one of the most
accessible people that i know in terms
of response time
and willingness to help willingness to
collaborate at the same time you're one
of the busiest people that i know
how how do you how does that happen how
are you so responsive
how do you how do you make yourself how
do you characterize yourself as a
persona that
as a person that people want to be
around because i want to learn from that
so when i was finishing school i wrote
this paper
it was 30 page paper about my world
views and
it started with a summary of my
childhood and then it ended up at the
conclusion of like
what i believe uh there are things that
i believe that other people don't
believe
and so i made it into like a 20 bullet
point list and
really i concluded that i was shaped uh
by
being very lucky to be born to the
family that i'm part of so my siblings
my parents et cetera
my experience overcoming dyslexia uh all
the books that i read
listen to speechify and um the fact that
i have a tremendous bias towards action
uh i'm the type of person that always
raises his hand in class i think that
like at least
fifty percent of the time if i'm in the
audience or like ten thousand people in
the audience the cool person i was on
stage
i somehow end up on the stage um if i
have an idea i just immediately
go and do it and so i get to like
reality check myself a lot
um and one of those principles that i
realized over time
is if i have the opportunity to
significantly improve someone else's
life
with a short period of time do it yeah
um and it takes very little effort
for me to do that because number one i
just have a lot of energy in general
um so i don't sleep as much as most
people do uh number two
if i'm interacting with other human
beings boom it's like i have like three
extra engines that take into power um
and so that makes it easy for me and so
and i'd rather do something now than do
something later yeah and i have this
philosophy and i
developed it in college that when i have
a cool idea
ride that initial wave as fast as you
can and so you message me hey let's see
the signals are great how about this
time
this is another rule which is never ever
ever if you're trying to set a time ask
the other person
uh if they're like oh would you want to
do this yeah sure
what time do you want to do it no
you just wasted everybody's
time
always responds with absolutely how
about this time this day at this time
you always have to suggest the dates and
like two available times of the days
um and if you don't in my book it's rude
um
yeah and so if i have the opportunity to
help people i do
and usually it's in the form of helping
other people um
develop new habits or look oh habits or
learn new information
yeah and no because you know i think
it's just
in the in the age that we're in now
everything is so online and
and sometimes i just it's i find it
incredible how there are some people
that are online and they're so
responsive and you know how busy they
are and you know that they're doing a
million other things but they still find
a way to be very responsive
and you know one of my personal mentors
dana really he
he's i know him for any time i'll send
him something within 20 minutes i have a
response
and it blows my mind how can i get a
response that quickly from one of the
busiest people in the world
and my dad told me when i was young if
you want some if you want
something done give it to the busiest
person in the room and
so that's that's something that i've
been trying to adopt myself and thinking
okay if there's something that i can get
done within two minutes
then i just do it now i don't delay it i
don't write it down
because just writing it down to do will
take me about as much time as just doing
it
and and i definitely get a lot of
inspiration from the way that you
that you deal with everything around you
and and how proactive you are in doing
these things
a cliff you have to go back to helping
uh helping dyslexic people
learn and and be and be successful in
the world
but before that i need three words that
describe you
so many people are familiar with the
idea of iq intelligent quotients
intelligence quotient eq emotional
intelligence
there's a third one that most people
don't know about which is aq adversity
quotient so adversity quotient is the
measure of how good you are
when faced with an insurmountable
insurmountable challenge
um if you look at the population people
with alexia in the world
about half the people in prisons have
dyslexia
and forty percent of billionaires have
suffered wait half the people in prisons
have dyslexia
um because that's what happens what
happens is when you're young
if you're seven years old and you fail
the one thing you're supposed to be good
at
um eventually you end up stopping out of
school
um unless you have this gigantic motor
inside of you
then when everybody else tells you
you're lazy you're stupid
you're a failure wow i'm awesome
you just don't know it yet and then you
work your butt off to make sure that
everybody understands them
um and so once you build that internal
clock inside of you
um that feeds your confidence and
gives you perseverance to that degree
you're unstoppable
and so it's almost like trial by fire at
a very young age
so the first one is i'm a person who
just has super high
adversity portion
the second one is i would either say
like confidence or charismatic
um and that's also something that's like
cultivated over time and you know what
books have been super helpful for that
um i highly recommend how to win friends
by dale carnegie yeah
um and the third one
part of me wants to be like
intellectually curious or like
introspective but actually kind-hearted
is more important
so kind-hearted would be the third one i
love it
cliff thank you so much this was this
was a pleasure